[Music]
Mass Effect Andromeda is on the horizon
and yes I am totally proud of that pun
the new space adventure is looking to be
pretty different from the original
trilogy a new galaxy means we'll be
exploring new planets with new aliens
using new powers and weapons here are
seven big changes you can look forward
to when the game launches number one
piloting the tempest shepard had the
Normandy in the original trilogy but the
riders siblings command the new Tempest
this time around I'm sure you remember
gliding around that miniature galaxy map
if only because of that awesome music
and flying around Andromeda is similar
only this time you'll stand on the
bridge of your ship and gaze out at the
Stars to choose your destination
the trade-off Bioware has said there
will be no loading screens from ship to
planet making your trips totally
seamless number two new and returning
species so when you step off the tempest
on these new planets what sort of alien
species can you expect to see well
you'll have a Krogan named Drac a turian
named veteran and an asari named PB and
your party as four new species Bioware
has already given us a sneak peek at the
evil ket we'll also be going up against
the remnants whatever they are in the
name of another new race called the
Angora has also been spotted the studio
also said that not all races are
returning in Andromeda and considering
the new setting
I wouldn't expect to see any keepers
from the Citadel but fingers crossed for
some Elcor number three exploring the
Nexus speaking of the Citadel it's gone
your new home away from home is the
Nexus which has been called a more
streamlined version of the old hub world
despite its smaller size it still packs
an archived history of the galaxy's
security centres science lab and
off-duty lounge some sort of Nexus level
can also be seen in the game's Paul's
menu so perhaps upgrading the hub world
opens up more planets to explore number
four resource mining and crafting
while you're cruising around those
planets in the Nomad be on the lookout
for resources Andromeda has new mining
and crafting options for weapons and
armor you'll find blueprints throughout
the game that you can use to upgrade
your gear and your new scanner can
collect minerals from various sources
these are then funneled into mods and
improvements for your loadout number
five more mobile combat of course not
everything on these planets is going to
play nice Bioware has said that the
game's combat is more mobile this time
around and it shows biotic charges can
be combined with jetpack boosts to shoot
all around the battlefield stunning
enemies in your path we've also seen a
sort of biotic shield in action which is
much more mobile than a previous games
bubble shield the developers have also
commented on finding that balance
between RPG and FPS gameplay and these
changes to combat seem to be working in
their favor
number 6 environmental hazards you see
it's not just hostile troops you have to
watch out for Andromeda also has a
variety of environmental hazards we've
seen a heat meter in the gameplay videos
so odds are we'll have to watch out for
extremely cold and poisonous
environments as well
random giant creatures can also attack
the party while exploring so you won't
be able to just trot around the surface
all willy-nilly number 7 loyalty
missions and side activities so you can
mine for resources and fight enemies on
the new planets what else
well foil T missions are back and so are
those steamy romance options but this
time they're not tied to the story
they're more like side quests and you
can complete them even after you finish
the campaign other side activities
include clearing enemy bases and those
are a bit more story centric Bioware
says taking these on won't be easy as
the bases are loaded with tough enemy
forces and plenty of alarms to let them
know that writer and the party have
arrived
Mass Effect Andromeda doesn't have a
solid release date yet but we know it's
coming to ps4 Xbox one and PC in spring
2017 Mass Effect 3 launched in 2012 so
Bioware has had plenty of time to make
changes to the franchise over almost 5
years which change excites you the most
is it one we missed let us know in the
comments and check out our ex
pensive breakdown of the latest gameplay
trailer while you're at it for all the
Mass Effect Andromeda coverage you need
you're already in the right place
you